and we have a guest with christian
larry you picked it up where you left it
off last year with a game against uh
kaidanov how did you strategize that
battle um well yesterday yeah i thought
i had an edge yesterday um looking look
looking for revenge and then i sort of
faded
um near the end i think i was plus two
or something and let him off the hook
today was a better
better let's let's take a look at
today's game you played with the black
pieces was the strategy to try to
complicate matters as fast as possible
um you know i looked like a lame opening
but that
second thought it looked pretty
dangerous after
93. it wasn't
i was planning queenie four that guy i
think that would have gotten me into
bigger trouble i may have been in
trouble here actually i think queenie
four was the best movie engine
i thought f3 and
or something like that queen's g6 i was
afraid of something like night i don't
know knight c4 trash is that working oh
my goodness
and if you take and then king december
some sort of nightmare
no b but my basics might be
who knows like probably black and castle
castle
like a maniac yeah it's probably good
for black
but you know
i wasn't quite sure of my
calculating ability looked a little
dangerous but you decided against the
queen e4 and chose the more tame queen
uh v8 um were you surprised by this
exchange on e7 we were actually looking
at this move
i was up for i was a little nervous
about g4 not that it's i'm not sure i'm
quite dead but no no no but he ate i
think i go rookie eight
he has some you know some
g5 maybe bishop g2 just some solid
development the knight c6 i guess and
uh bishop f8 perhaps and then 94 maybe
at some point maybe yeah
i think i may have even had that in the
game i was
i thought that was a little too simple
but you were a bit worried i was a
little nervous i would have played that
myself yes
that's what we
thought as well yeah okay so here he's
got a little problem with this okay so
here's a tough call i was thinking about
eating things like e3
didn't quite work
you know the sack
i think he plays knight e3 and wasn't
quite working for me
the queen's c you know now that stuff so
this looked like the logic
after e3 knight takes e3 we exchanged
that
d5 yeah there was a knight e3 knight
takes bishop takes bishop f5 i guess f5
yes but then he plays uh
i think he has queen g5 right
yeah he has exactly queen g5 or queen oh
yeah that's right
forget it it's not working
and what if you go bishop d5 to have
that bishop protected yeah then i think
bishop d5 he's got bishop h6 that he
saves oh very nice yeah
yeah that keeps uh i'm
up up the goal zoo here up the creek
keep seymour life for sure yeah all
right so you decided against e3 yeah
bishop here
so you know i like rook lifts i've been
talking about it for years so now you
know classic
i have some nebulous pressure you know
cheat a lot of cheapos i look you know
looking for those cheapos on h3 and so
forth so you were feeling comfortable
at this point i knew i was it was
complicated i think i played queen eight
didn't i no i played
at the beginning quincy
yeah yes i played queen eight later yes
and now it get uh now it clarifies a bit
i thought i had pressure
uh well i do have pressure i think did
you feel like he misassessed uh this
position yeah it's uh because of that
you know i mean earlier
i'm going to lose it he's going to lose
a pawn and plus perpetual pressure on g2
you know the poor guy i mean he's got a
passive bishop hard to make loof without
you know
um something bad happening and and you
assessed it uh perfectly because
actually the computer says you're
completely winning at this point oh
really completely winning yeah i looked
like it was
good chances so yeah at this point i
thought it was comfortable when yes
absolutely maybe two pawns up you know i
have to be careful
you know he actually had this move after
rook to d3 yeah this uh well save to
save one more pawn that is bishop to e1
there should be one here yes would you
spot this uh
well then i think i would resource i
would keep the
queen i would keep queen c2 queen to c2
yes keep the pressure going
and then you know look so he's got to be
careful about uh winning two maybe
well queen here plays queenie too okay
yeah and he's um hanging in there
try to get the same end game but with
the pawn on hdmi still that's a big
difference yeah
but he did not spot that and after that
you just yeah d3 i think was all over
we were a little surprised larry by rook
to d3 we thought queen c2
made a lot more sense just you know
pounding the pawn on g yeah um yeah i
was uh i i saw queen c2 look promising i
didn't rook d3 looked like you know two
pawns up okay so i mean
and i think it's only because of bishop
to e1 that he gets to stay in the game
if he doesn't see that then he's out
yeah i mean this is just toward you know
pure torture yeah
i think i could trade ruxin must be
winning too right yeah sure what's the
what's the diagnosis
it's probably winning the two pawns but
i like your decision yeah
why bother with that yeah i mean you're
you you you your rook is actually really
you know yeah escort service and g2
pressure yeah what kind of service
escort service
yeah it's a family show
[Laughter]
nice
uh feeling good larry you got one and a
half points out of two nice start
what did you think about igor novocop's
victory coming
uh
in round one
that was um where he came from from a
bad position yeah quite a quite a um
comeback counter-attack exactly exactly
yeah he's a tough customer with black
with the black pieces he's real tough
coming into the tournament larry who did
you think were the favorites
uh well the young guys
copian joel
the young guy
[Laughter]
how did you rate your own chances
seriously i'll be honest can i have
modest goals here
how i just said you have a well i'm
actually more concerned about you know
breaking three million six hundred and
fifty thousand steps
for the year of 2022. oh wow say what
yeah look i'm a nut a nut on this whole
thing this is what are you using that is
yeah the applications so i have to add
my numbers
walking around the tournament hall it's
one of the you know another gm quirk
excellent well give me the number again
first of all three uh that's you know
ten thousand days uh steps per day
on average uh three hundred three
million six hundred fifty that's a lot
of stuff like going across the country
twice or something
so
yeah
something to look forward to
very nice and st louis is a great
walking
town actually throughout here
great park and all that
foreign next to us absolutely larry
congratulations we'll see you in the
next few years okay thanks thank you
thank you for joining us
three million six hundred fifty thousand
steps like what i thought i was gonna
say dollar so i was like yeah